Good afternoon, I welcome
everyone who is joining us here at
Yale and everyone who is
participating from around the world in
our second session of the series on
Latin American political leaders, which
will deal with sustainable development
in Latin America. My name is  claudia
valeria i am professor of anthropology and
president of the latin american council for
latin american and iberian studies
at yale university
the latin american political leaders series
is generously
supported by the george herbert walker junior
lacouture fund in
international studies mckale center
east 20 would not  been possible without the
help of our collaborators in the
office of international affairs the
foxx international scholarship program and
the peace and development program thanks
to all of you
today I have the great honor of
presenting two top-
level Ecuadorians first I will present Jessica
Faieta  our distinguished model  speaker
for this session and then i will introduce
our industry speaker yolanda
kakabadse
jessica faieta is currently a senior
fellow at the jackson institute global
affairs here at geo we have
also been fortunate to have her as a workflow
in the recent past
jessica has over 30 years of
distinguished service  at the united nations
she is ecuadorian and has a masters
in international affairs and a post
from columbia university in new york
among her many mistakes jessica
served as director of the
haiti menu after the devastating
2010 earthquake she led the un in el salvador
belize and more recently in colombia and he
also served in the
executive office of the secretary general of the
united nations kofi annan
well now before introducing our
distinguished speaker i want to share a
few words about the series on
latin american political leaders
the series seeks to create a  dialogue about the
future  of democratization
human rights and development with
political leaders from across the region
we look forward to engaging these
leaders in a healthy and
respectful discussion on pressing issues in
our region for this reason I
am pleased to welcome yolanda
kakabadse to speak on the first
theme of sustainable development in
latin america' yolanda kakabadse is the
ideal speaker for this event in the
series that arrives in the same week
that we celebrate
international women's day
yolanda's work with the
environmental conservation movement began in the  year
1979 when she was appointed
executive director of the natura foundation in
egypt from 1990 to 1922 yolanda
coordinated the participation
of civil society organizations for
the united nations
conference on environment and development
in 1993 she created the latin american future foundation
an organization  which aims at
sustainable development through
of conflict prevention
was executive president of the
foundation until 2006 and remains
chair of the president of the advisory council
from 1996 to 2004 in 2004 she was president of
the world conservation union and a
member of the board of directors of
the world resources institute
yolanda  she was appointed minister of the
environment of the republic of ecuador- a
position she held from
1998 to 2000
from 2010 to 2017 she was the president
of the world fund for nature
please join me in
welcoming a true pioneering leader
of environmental policy  in
latin america' the second speaker in our
series on leaders and leaders in
latin
american politics yolanda kakabadse thank you very much
claudia your presentation is beautiful and how nice to
feel welcome in a place
like yale that I have very close to my
heart I was there 20 years ago  a little
over 20 years in the year 21 and of
course my memories and my links
yale has been permanent
so happy to be with you
and the idea of talking about susta
nable development about climate change about what
s happening in the region is alway
attractive because in latin
america things happen at full speed much
ore  faster than we can
count them and sustainability or
lack of sustainability is
permanently coming in waves we
feel good we feel lousy we
criticize we do not welcome
new situations and policies and maybe
because we are living in a world as
special as it is
I dare  to start with there
the invitation is culminating or I don't know if it
is culminating but it seems that it is going to
come to an end and we are in a
situation in which we are all
looking for good and now what is going to
happen next
and maybe what I would like  is to link
the results of the cob it with the
sustainability of latin america and my
first reaction is i don't want
us to go back to normality
because  what happened during
normality was fatal in what is the
so-called normality in quotes that
has led us to the situation we
are in and the situation we are
in is of course terrible and begins with
the recognition that the planet  is
sick
and therefore society is sick
the young person is nothing but a result of
mistreatment of
the planet so
living in a continent that is so rich so
special so diverse so wonderful what
we have to do is look good if
we have all that
what can we do to  that we really
recover or we head
towards a world a more sustainable planet
towards a Latin America that gives us a
lot of satisfaction
and of course we have no choice but
to
make some comments about what is
sustainability that is the famous climate change
talking yesterday with
Jessica we said
that the lack of coherence we have in
calling climate change change
is not change, change is good
change if we change our shoes
if we change our clothes if we
change our jobs if we change our
career and place of life I even think
that if we change our partner all this
must be good it is not true because we
call it such a horrible thing
horrible as the climate change crisis we are
experiencing I think we
have to be more frontal and call it a
climate crisis
and the climate crisis is tremendous but
above all it is
unknown
I am not a scientist I am not an expert in the
climate crisis or in climate the only
thing I know is  I don't understand anything
and they speak to me in a
tremendously difficult language full of acronyms and
full of one of technological terms
that I don't understand, I have no idea
how to explain what is happening to the
planet and the only way to refer to
these changes is to say  that it is an
error network and we are not prepared to
face it, but I think the great challenge is
to prepare ourselves to face it by
understanding what is happening, and I
would love to do that  talk to jessica because
she is a person who has been
involved in these issues
for so many years that you probably give me the reason that
we do not understand because it seems to me that part
of the power of powerful groups is to
keep
the discussion between the super
experts closed  and not allow the
information to permeate towards the common and
wild citizen that we all are
well yolanda thanks for the invitation
to talk and what a great honor and
privilege we both have to be here
in this environment of
yale university thanks to claudia a  his team and the
council of Latin American and
Iberian studies that have allowed
these two Ecuadorians who in one
way or another have long been
committed to the development of the
region
with the environment so what a great
privilege for me and yolanda  to talk
about this so I am watching you with great
interest and I also hope that the
students and the students of jay that
n  They are listening to you and all those who are
connected can also
benefit from your thought of eto'o
of wisdom in this time and
what I would like a little bit is that you
tell me why, that is, when you talk
about it
I  I really think
look at the last few times that we have
been I think we have been talking
we have even recently talked about
one of my last things I did
before retiring from the UN to come to and he
was launching the last
human development report on Peru and we talked about
the Anthropocene in  the one we are talking about that
only there is a very very
difficult word to understand but it has to
do precisely with what you are saying
with what the mistreatment of the planet but
this time
of the human being to the planet so
tell me a little from your point of
view  for example, how is your
role as human beings in the conservation of the
planet but also in the destruction
of the planet, how can people
contribute and good  not what they have done that
maybe it can be reversed at this
point
thanks jessica right not two
Ecuadorians talking with all of
you how nice
to see I feel that on all
continents and in almost all countries
I think there are some
exceptions out there  like bhutan for example the
culture that is dominating at the
moment is that of consumption
and consuming more that is the purpose of
the young university student who comes out
prepared to face the world is
how to promote consumption perhaps without
using those words but promoting
steps and actions that what they do is
tempt the consumer to have more
instead of being more, and having more implies
many things.
Fortunately, I do not like the
typical windows shopping to go find
something new to wear, but what else  It
scares me to see some signs in all the
windows that say I bought three for the
value of one
and of course I don't need three
I went to look for one and the temptation
that I am going to pay less and buy 13 is
huge so the consumer comes out with 3
and we see that
we really fall into one in a culture without
questioning without questioning because I am
buying three I love it when I go to
the San Francisco area to see a
number of stores  that they sell
used clothes or clothes that were not used but that are there
to resell is not true because
the consumer realized so that I
brought them home or I really didn't like them
and therefore I tried them on and
put them there at the  sale but that is how
we are reacting instead of saying let's
consume less and I would like to touch on a
subject
jessica and friends all that the
same thing is happening in food
and that is a subject in which I am passionately involved
because it is in vain  that because I know that
I am some thinkers of this
precisely
from the food expert at a time when the
world has so many people literally
starving to death it is something something
tremendous explain us a little  uito more than
that which is fascinated
claudia and jessica tonight we are at
the same time here in ecuador and at yale
tonight
810 million people go to sleep without eating
and today we are going to throw away
40% of the food that  40 40 were produced today
and that for me is immoral it
has an impressive lack of ethics
while 810 million people go
to sleep without eating we throw away 40% of the
food that is produced in the field in
transport in refrigeration in
packaging  in the market and in
our homes in the refrigerator of
our home
40% of the food goes to waste
it means that
we put aside
the finger points and it is not true who
we blame for this but that
means  that we are living
as a loss of enormous values of solid
rity and awareness that
his tomato that is going to waste is part
f the planet and therefore it is re
lecting that our links with
he planet are extremely weak  s and
that has a lot to do with education, of
course, of course, most of
you there at yale learn learn
about those values and learn about the impor
ance of the planet and strengthen those
ties but we realize when
e look around us that they
re not norma
I was recently talking to a young girl
like you,
Washington students from a university, very good
language, what Ireland
told me, I have enough money for one meal
a day,
even though I am in a
super privileged university, I can only eat
once  a day and therefore what this
girl did is generate a process to
produce a survey asking
how many other boys at the
university the same thing was happening to her and
she got a huge scare to see that she
was not the only one who had  a world of
students who could not
afford more than one meal
a day and went to work with
restaurants in the neighborhood of  their
university so that these restaurants
at the end of the day would deliver the
food that they did not have that was
not sold that day and it served
this girl to distribute among the
students who needed it but
I insist again the issue is that we
are not  aware of the good or evil
that we are generating for the planet
and not questioning a series of practices
that seem to come to us because that
is the way the world is instead of questioning
why we are in these practices and in
this consumer culture that does not
force us  to link that it is the planet
that gives us or that threatens us and of
course in Latin America we are
experiencing very serious threats it is not
true we have seen in recent
months year a number of landslides a
number of river growth that
destroy entire communities  that
destroy entire infrastructure on
which those citizens depend that
destroy lives human lives that the
other extreme does not certain droughts that
destroy  yen and what was potentially going to
be the source of life and the source of
economic resources for many
individuals, families
and populations, so Latin America
is experiencing what the rest of the world
is not at all different about, what is different is that
we live on a planet that is a  test, that is to
say, in a region that is extremely rich and
we do not know how to recognize that wealth, we are
stepping on wealth and we mistreat it, we are
living off wealth and we do not pay attention to it
and on the contrary we are generating
destructive processes that will mean that
sooner or later the region will also have
to say  the water has run out we have nothing
to irrigate
our cities we cannot
offer them food or drinking water
or fertile soil the amount of soil
depleted and destroyed by bad
agricultural practices is tremendous and it is not
that agriculture is bad it is the
agricultural practices that we are
creating by imitating
using are tremendously
destructive and what they do is every time
reduce that wonderful wealth  sa from
latin america
yolanda look as i listen to you and remember
one of the things that has touched me to
lead has been the response
in my last career in the last
five years only to three
category 5 hurricanes in our region the
most recent hurricane and  another one that
devastated the island of providencia in
colombia and in 2017
the hurricanes irma and mariah that
devastated the island states of the caribbean
so i really have seen
first hand what they do what
really is this climate crisis that
you call it is me  making our
region and above all the countries
more vulnerable then it really is
very real it is very real for our for
our region and look at that I know that
every state with several committed thinkers from the
region have been
developing a series of proposals
and  principles for a sustainable future
of
latin america why don't you tell us a
little about those about those
principles that you would think we have already h  Talking of
course about transiting, hopefully we will transit
more towards a circular economy towards
one, let's say, more
regenerative, more restorative agroforestry systems, but
tell me what this group of thinkers
that you have directed
to this proposed,
what a beautiful question, Jessica, and I will begin by
saying that there are many Latin Americans
like you  that we are constantly
thinking about the region that we are concerned about
the region and of course we do not have
the energy to worry about the
entire planet so we have focused
on Latin America and the Caribbean and what we
see is a lot of effort to
think and to put  in action a series
of practices or
propose changes different from what we
are experiencing at this time in the
region
that I see as the great challenges
at this time the first place I said is
the awareness of what we have
there are few citizens who are
They worry about knowing what those
riches are, on the contrary, there are people who
aspire to v  Live in other forms of life
that depend a lot on the consumption
of production and consumption instead
of thinking about what is the natural capital
that Latin America has and how we
can use it better then
awareness that we do not live in a poor continent
but
exceptionally  rich and that can give us a
lot
we see fortunately we see
many groups,
especially young people who are working on this
issue that they are trying to innovate like
how
plastic packaging was replaced by something natural
I don't know if they all
use the same word for
describe a product one by one
one of the typical products of
latin america is cassava you know
what i'm talking about
cassava is a root casa vale they say
in english es la casada and you are
cassava we say cassava also here in
ecuador in  Quito we have a university
where there is a group working with cassava and
producing a film that sees it and you
can't believe it because it's just like
plastic rap to that horrible thing
called plastic grab and that soon I think we
will be able to see
using that material that material
in packaging things
and we see that they are looking for ways
in which
products that are considered garbage
can become
ingredients for medical treatments
we see
that this concept that is global and
that solutions based on nature
are generating roots in cultures is not
true in cultures of
planting species that were here
in our region before and that have been
almost lost in our culture  and I am talking
about one of them, for example,
bamboo, American bamboo from the tropical part of
America and Colombia and Ecuador, they are very
rich in it, the guadúa cane is from it, it
is among the seven most powerful of
all bamboo species and
yet we are importing  Chinese bamboo
and those are the absurdities, it is not true that
we have neglected and almost abandoned
the protection of the bamboo cane in
our continent and it is the plant that
grows the fastest it lasts 90 years it is cut
from a stem and it grows again the plant
lasts 90 years
and every year it gives us a new shoot that
can feed a whole family
so how do we change from that
mentality  that
what is outside is not necessarily good but what is inside is
also as I would love to see kids
who are studying there and who are
creating as I would love to see that
school desks,
kitchen furniture and
office furniture are  made with bamboo cane
instead of metal or instead of wood and
many times native wood is not true
of native trees when we could
be planting bamboo cane in the tropics of our
America, which is the plant
that absorbs the most carbon
explain what it means  that because I
am repeating a language that I
do not know but it is supposed to be a
great plant to reduce the impact of
the climate crisis it
retains water lasts 90 years
and can  of growing up in many regions of
our america had given us three
examples only of a
natural potential that is in our region and that
and that we mistreat it and we vote for it
but returning to
Jessica's question that no more where
are those principles of america  latina
I think that one of the great
weaknesses is the lack of knowledge of the
value of science and there we are
working from all over,
from Mexico to Patagonia
the latin american has not grown up with a
culture of valuing the science
of science that is at the  our side
many times science from
local communities and other times science that
is produced or developed in
academic centers or
scientific research institutes this is a
great weakness of our latin america
and perhaps one of the reasons why
we  hit the commit so much is not true
because we were not prepared to
understand or develop answers
to science and I think that  there we have to
work much harder to recognize
science, the ancestral knowledge of
local communities and to promote the
recognition of scientific information
and perhaps there,
jessica and claudia, we need to
develop in all the universities and
hopefully yale is already working on that to
create capacities  To interpret
science, the scientist is not
necessarily a good communicator, he is generally
a bad communicator, but he does not have to
be good, his great ability is to
investigate and produce wonderful documents
to which no one has access because
we lack that interpreter who can
translate for me 500  pages on a page of
a public policy proposal you
look at that void it's huge sorry if
you don't have it there look absolutely right
because you have also touched on something
so important which is ancestral wisdom
and the role that peoples play for
example  indigenous people in the
very conservation of our forests
and also
especially  native species that little by little we are
beginning to see here in the
supermarket of the new heaven for
example
that are native species of our
region but that at
the same time contain species
that can restore regenerate and
also have that component
very strong food such as quinoa, asa and
sacha inchi, moringa to all these
new species that have really been
used for centuries by our
Amazonian indigenous peoples and that now they are
recognizing how they are, they are also
products that contribute to that
feed the organic and that in turn
can be this because they can be this is
this this balance that the
sustainable development goals and the people of
2030 expected that the development of the
world
at the same time
economic of course we need
growth to be social in the sense that
benefits the population but that
they are also 20 environmentally
positive and in that look seeing some of
the questions, do you think that
companies that play such an
important role in conservation can
have this balance of making their
investments in a way that at the
same time has a
financial economic benefit but that
can also make an environmental and
At the same time, I have seen companies in
our region that do what they do. Do you
think there is enough movement
for companies to
come to
adopt, let's say these practices that
we see a little more broadly, for example, I
think there are large
multinational companies that  They are genuinely
adopting positive practices with the
environment. As you can see, many people in the
region diego, but perhaps
what surprises me the most is to see
small and medium-sized companies in this and
some new companies. I am talking about
Packard chocolate in Ecuador, and it was a
success.  that it wins prizes all
over the world that it is promoting
the care of the soil in the
c plantations  Acao that
it has a policy of
hiring women
and I see for example the production of
quinoa in Ecuador quinoa for
export
that has been developing for a
long time I would say more than 15 years
with women peasant women from
up there as you know  Quinoa
grows at altitudes of more than 3,000
meters and cooperatives of women who
hire their husbands so that they have
work because they developed through
the company have their
export channels and are very clear about
where to go and thus a series of initiatives
that  that what they are trying to do is promote
principles of equality between the men and
women who are their workers, to
improve wages, to improve
working conditions, which often
involves gloves, masks, boots so
that people, workers, are not
contaminated with any product, and
speaking of contamination  of products
companies that are
and are using agrochemicals or
eliminating the use of agroq  chemicals to
offer the consumer organic products
that in the field of agriculture
so if you see if you see that there is
that energy of young people who now enter
the supermarket like a mobile phone
that takes a photo of the product and
the link gives them  says if it is a
product that must be acquired or
taken care of, do not buy that because it pollutes
because it does not treat workers well
because it comes from processes that are not
sustainable, then there is all that
element of new technologies together with
new aspirations of the young population
that is looking for  something different but
the product is still dominated by the culture of
production and irrational consumption
and hopefully we will also move
towards this culture of circular economy
of the organic economy of these
agroforestry systems let's say
less harmful to the environment
look I'm going to read some questions
we have  but what you
are saying is very relevant and above all addressed
to the e  students to yale students
look here we have a a
question from an environmental studies student
who tells us that they are here
because they are having trouble
deciding which career within the
subject let's say that in charge within the
field of conservation
would be more interesting than  Would you recommend,
on the one hand, he is interested in what
policies are, but he is also interested in
contributing directly to
leading conservation projects,
so to the students who are
listening to us, what would you recommend
with their studies in their training to
make these new citizens
who have a conscience
with the planet
what a beautiful question if I were to be born again
I would like to study two things together
environmental policy and economics
because we live in a world where
the relative value of one
decision or the other must be demonstrated and I believe that the great
deficit of environmentalists to
global level and in our region is that we
cannot demonstrate that generally the
we feel from the viscera it is not true
that this decision is good but I
have to show the president or the
decision-maker at that moment that if I leave that
tree standing it has more value than if I
cut it down and make wood but I need
solid arguments
I need to remember  An experience of mine
when I was a minister who had to
reach an agreement with the
Galapagos fishing sector on how many
units of sea cucumber they could fish
per year and I did not know whether to give them
authorization for 10 for 100 for
100,000 for a million I had no idea
why  I didn't know what the use of
the sea cucumber was in the sea
and if leaving it in the sea was more
important than selling it to asia not a
certain galaxy than to southeast
Asia that loves the
sea cucumber and to me it seemed horrible
but  well, that was a way of
developing an economic activity for
these fishermen and I couldn't prove that in
the end I reached an agreement based
on rationality, not a rule that  let
's say I don't remember how much
we want in a hundred thousand,
but why not 120,000 or 150,000? I
had no arguments
and that type of analysis of the
economic value of conservation is super
important
if I don't show another example of another
extreme if I don't show that  the sulfur
in gasoline is reducing the
intelligence of young children and
unborn children, that is, those
in the womb
no I do not have the argument to tell
the scissor to eliminate forever the
sulfur or other chemical is not true  and not
necessarily sulfur but I have
to show that intelligence has
a value
and that intelligence is being
affected by the inhalation of harmful gases
if I don't show it with numbers my
emotions that want to defend those
children are not enough and so on  life
mind it is not true how important
this recommendation is that I spend that
really in these times you do not need to
know as
much about economics as you do about science and
of the social impact and look, I am currently
editing a course at
yale called
challenges
berman challenges of latin american and
caribbean and precisely of the challenges of
and one of my classes I have always
emphasized the interconnectivity
of development issues that  We can
talk about reducing poverty without taking care of
development or without talking about the
labor insertion of women
or, for example, the role of
indigenous peoples, so this
really is sustainability or being a
professional who is interested in
sustainable development issues  conservation
has to be an inter and
interdisciplinary issue and it seems to me that it is
something that must be given a lot of credit to
yale because precisely because they have one
of the first and best
environmental schools here that has
precisely that
interdisciplinary approach  where it has the
scientific but also
economic, social and international focus that it
has, so I am happy  ra that you say it,
look, following a little with the
questions that we have, in fact,
we have one here, it
seems that we have an Ecuadorian student, it is
good that he is also very
kindly saying that he is proud
of the work he does to improve the
environment,
I  what is here what is
also since you named your role as
minister of the environment let's talk a
little about the role of governments is not
true of the role of governments and
also of the different
interests that governments have and
pulled by different interests
different policies and that they have to
comply with how you see
development as how I was was your
management, let's say the challenges that dress you
as on the one hand being in the government
and now that you have been on the side
of the NGOs you have also been on the side
side of the environmental movements
as you see in the role of governments
in conservation
absolutely vital essential
I feel and during that period  As a
minister, I felt that the role of the government
is to lay out the court
here in this court tennis is played if
someone wants to come and play ping pong
it will not go well but it is the
government that decides what the
legal and development policy limits are  that
are there inside that field and not
interfere
act when that society that
is in your country needs your support
but not take away the role of the citizen
take away the energies of those of the
organized groups that is the worst thing that
a government can do  The government has to
support and encourage the visibility of the
role of citizens and I feel
that it is a way of building a country
that the best way to
aim for the success of a country is to ensure
that the strengthening of
the individual citizen when  he feels that his
creativity can build that his
participation is essential in a country
without
active citizens in participation never grows
and I think it's nice to see a
society  ad from a country that is informed that it
is undergoing transparency processes where it
has the information it needs from the
government to be able to make
decisions to be able to promote and
involve new actors that is the
role of a government
and along the same lines that you would say  you the role
of the laws only of the legislators
that they make
and also that they also ask us here
what the role of the initiatives of the
laws in our region as you see the
role of the legislators the legislators
have this they have this
let's say the knowledge the
sensitivity  As for making the laws
that we need at the moment,
I believe that there is a great deficit,
but it is a deficit that we see in
parliaments generated by the lack of
information and education of
citizens in general, because what
parliaments are is nothing more than  a reflection of
society we cannot expect from them
something better than what is seen in the rest
of the country
if the citizens are not informed about the
cand  data are going to be bad candidates
and legislators are going to be bad
legislators
and we find that there are laws and
policies outlined in national congresses
that contradict logic or
contradict other laws but that is
our fault we elect them and
they are the ones who  they are there and legislating
in our name as a conclusion jessica
and who is interested in these
issues if we do not invest much
more in training citizens we
are not going to have better legislators
no definitely look and the role of
environmental education that starts very
early  I believe that in this, well,
progress has been made in
the region in creating children who
are more environmentally aware, I do not think
that we have to
advance that much more in housing,
in universities, to have more careers,
I have seen in  the curricula of many
universities where there is already a degree,
let's say from environmental management to the
environmental development degree  and well more
opportunities I think there is a need for
more of that because precisely because there
is already much more that can
be done creating both
in this consciousness this knowledge in
the sciences
from young people from children of
people my opinion is that  Like you,
it
is precisely the older people
who are now in positions of
power, making the laws, making
them, for which we need to
reach them more, and well, exactly how
would we do it, let's say we would buy, because I
really see it there and perhaps  That
lack
of knowledge, perhaps, but also of
awareness, is not one of the things that
we saw in this when we were here. It was
my turn to also face
the problem. They will help me support the
Colombian government in responding to the pandemic and
at that time.  Well, the Secretary General
of the UN had a speech that he
continues to maintain, of course, that it is
time to invest
precisely in nature, yes  The countries
have to recover economically
from the blow they had in the pandemic, so let's
take advantage of these investments so
that they are investments in
renewable energies,
investments such as creating and
bringing connectivity to the towns in the
most remote places in our region and
at the same time, generating  with
solar energy, for example, but joining these
technologies to allow let's see what I know
that investments also
recover jobs but that at the same time
they are green I don't know if you have seen
you have seen now I attend the
truth it seemed like a very good speech
in we promoted it in from the
united nations but I don't know if we have really
achieved that the governments for example
[Music]
even many of the efforts that were
already being made in our region
around following the
renewable energy movements some were even
left aside
around the pandemic I don't know what
your
experience has been that you've seen in the
recovery of our region as in
the vision at the time of the pandemic
jessica has been a good time to
rethink development projects
as the decision makers
were able to reevaluate what they were going to do
think better to modify some things
so that these investments are
minors
and I believe that some important decisions have been made in the region
to
strengthen the capacity of renewable
energies that lead to replace
those of fossil fuel schools
I believe that
those decisions
related to energy and related to
the global debates on the
climate crisis are
becoming stronger  more and more
but again I would like to
mention the issue of
citizen awareness about why this is more
important or better and relate it
to an experience of the
united nations of a world that you have lived
jessica and that took place in new york
with ban ki-moon when he entered he was
surprised at the amount of air
conditioning  ionation and heating inside
the principal's new york building
and sent a note that circulated to all the
staff
and said in that note please
dress for the occasion if it's summer come
short-sleeved if it's winter bring
a jacket but don't  try to make
summer in winter or
winter in summer inside the
building they saved 30,000 dollars in
a month
because people went and wanted to live in an
artificial world not all of course
but many wanted to be in a coat
when it was the height of summer and  they wanted to go in
short sleeves when it was the middle of winter
and have the energy systems
of the building satisfy their
personal desire and of course I think that
through this type of behavior what
we have done is disassociate
ourselves from reality that is  good to be cold in
the winter not to freeze tea either but to
feel like you're living through winter and to
feel like you're living through summer and not
asking technology to fulfill your
personal wishes, so we also
need to work on generating that
awareness among our citizens
a few days ago when I was in Galapagos
the taxi driver tells me, ma'am, I'll put air
conditioning on him or he wants to open the window
but please talk to me at the window of the
taxi I don't want air conditioning  he
bursts out laughing and tells me this, you
can't imagine, ma'am, the number of
clients who ask me to close the
windows and put on air conditioning
in the middle of the Galapagos that type of
behavior we have to
question ourselves, it's not true, and learn to
laugh at them and to  change,
well, yolanda, well, I think it's a
very important message to let a
lot of this
climate crisis of the environmental crisis that
states that the plan is suffering at the moment, it
also starts
with us, I don't know if it can end with
us, because as  We have seen many
of the things that can hardly be
reversed, but if they manage to mitigate many
of the damage that  it is being done and it begins
with our behavior with our
own people like families
like students like academics like
businessmen so I think this is a
very important message to close
this that we only have
three minutes left so I am going to let you
make your final reflections and  Well, I
also took the opportunity to thank and
thank you enormously and Holland
for having
made you available for this
conversation and the students to the
students who have sent comments
that are connected and of course to
Claudia and her team and to the Council of
Studies and
Latin American Studies
and you will see from Ibero-America what it gives us that it
has indicated to us so this
important topic and again well wish you a
lot of success in so many
important things in so many supports that you have been
doing in the region so I leave you to
close with a few small reflections and
I passed the  word claudia
thank you million a very short reflection
all  we belong to a country
but the environment and the crisis we are
experiencing and the opportunities we have
cannot be seen within the limits
that are on a map only that they
are not in the reality that we live in or
in nature and I believe that all
Latin Americans  we have the obligation
to think about the ecosystem in what the
ecosystem that is the continent that is
the Pacific coast of the Atlantic of the
Caribbean that is the Amazon forest that is
the cuttlefish and many other
wonderful ecosystems that we have that of islands
is not true  ecuador has just created a
new area of the ocean that is a topic that I wou
d love to deal with in another opportunity of th
ocean together with the galapagos to make a cor
idor corridor ecuador costa rica colom
ia and panama where we have very
any islands and t
e four presidents lined up it is nice
o see that  exercise of
public conservation policy thinking about the
economy of our countries that cannot
grow if we destroy these species of the
ocean with a certainty and everyone loses
so think of latin america and
our region
as a whole as an entity that has
arms and legs and that if you cut off
baa1 the whole rest of the body loses so
let's think based on our
region and thank you all  you claudia
and all those who have helped you
organize this you are wonderful guys
well thank you both very much
it has really been a pleasure and an honor to be
able to listen to this dialogue that took
place and rescue the awareness
in all of us in the individual act
of  consume in the individual act of
refusing in the individual act of
educating the youngest
so I thank you very
much for taking a moment out of your
busy lives to share this dialogue
and I hope we continue the dialogue in a
very near future thank you very much
thanks to you too and cabrio landa and
thanks to the students who gave us
website today